she's right when she says Israel has
tried to compromise with a two-state
solution that they proposed a state for
the Palestinians but why did they
propose a state because they wanted
Palestinians to say do take give us the
land or we'll kill you and when they
proceeded to kill the Palestinians and
take the land the Arab States invaded so
she's right the UN offered partition the
Arab states rejected it and invaded
she's told the half truth yeah let's
finish the full truth let's finish all
of it let's talk about why it was
offered let's talk about why the Arab
States invaded let's talk about why they
invaded in a way that the US would
invade a country if another country like
Russia invaded Ukraine in order to drive
the ukrainians out of their homes